en este hospital infantil ruso los
ingresos no cesan son bebés niños y
adolescentes que llegan al hospital con
infecciones agudas por kobe 19 en el
número de pacientes aumentó
recientemente el joven 19 se hizo más
joven
puesto estamos admitiendo niños
adolescentes y niños recién nacidos
mixco wells de cuatro meses de ocho
meses de seis meses no sucedió en
oleadas anteriores de infección cuando
yoma karan ayer osment en el hospital se
encuentra en circus una ciudad en
siberia a más de 4000 kilómetros de
moscú según la jefa del departamento de
infecciones del hospital pediátrico la
enfermedad se ha hecho más grave que en
otras olas ahora los niños mayores los
adolescentes reciben más a menudo
oxígeno se someten a una poderosa
terapia de infusión terapia anti
bacterial la duración de la enfermedad
también ha aumentado
rusia en general atraviesa un nuevo pico
de la pandemia con una cifra récord de
40 mil 251 casos de kobe 19 sólo este
sábado según la universidad johns
hopkins apenas el 32 puntos 72 por
ciento de la población se ha vacunado el
personal de la salud exhausto hace un
llamado a recibir los biológicos se
hacen aún y no es la principal fuente de
la enfermedad son los adultos sus
prendas la salud de los niños depende de
ello por eso hay que vacunarse
russia amaneció en medio de unas
vacaciones pagadas una estrategia del
gobierno de vladímir putin para que la
ciudadanía permanezca en sus hogares
buscando contener la rápida alza de los
casos que atraviesa el país